to describe dota2 to my mom my family or
someone you asked me it's something
right I don't even know where to start
best of luck to anybody trying to fit
dota into a hundred words it's really
hard to explain dota 2 is five people
trying to take down another team of
fives base I think it's like a virtual
chess way there's a lot of actual
mechanics involved dota is like no other
game there's 110 different individual
pieces of chess and now you have to
learn everything that bad chess piece
could do that chess piece could do now
for things you don't have turns you just
move all the time then you have a throne
to defend you have to be able to have
really fast reaction time you have to
have great hand-eye coordination it's
something similar to like capture the
flag I've heard that people compared to
basketball because that's this team
aspect you have to work together you
have to overcome differences if I call
it Wizard s football there is so much
depth to the game that it's almost
impossible to simplify once you learn it
you'll never give it up